- [Instructor] As we've
mentioned in previous videos,
Hinduism is a very diverse religion,
with many different practices,
and even different beliefs,
but there is a core
centered around scripture.
And the most important of
these texts are the Vedas.
Now the word Veda literally
means knowledge in Sanskrit,
and they were written
during the Vedic Period.
It was called the Vedic Period
because this was the time
that we believe the Vedas were written,
and we have a whole video
on the actual Vedic Period.
Now there are four Vedas: Rigveda,
Yajurveda, Samaveda, and Atharvaveda.
The first of these is the Rigveda.
When I say first, it's
because it's believed
that it was written
before the other Vedas,
as early as 3,500 years ago.
The other three are also pretty old,
probably older than 3,000 years old.
Now these four texts are
a combination of rituals,
of hymns, of mantras, of
songs, and of philosophy.
For example Rigveda, Rig you can translate
as meaning praise, so it's
knowledge of ways to praise,
praise the eternal, or praise God.
Yajurveda you could view
as these prose mantras,
knowledge of these prose
mantras, is Yajurveda.
Samaveda, this is knowledge
of songs or hymns.
Atharvaveda, you can view
these as knowledge of
things that you should do in your life.
Now these four texts can be sub-classified
into the type of text
that they actually are.
So what you see here is
the sub-classification
of the Vedas that's often referenced,
that amongst these texts some of the
verses are mantras, hymns, prayers,
those are referred to as Samhitas.
You have the things that are more rituals,
ceremonies, these are Aranyakas.
And Aranyakas are also
things being referred to,
things that you have learned, or rituals
to do in the forest, maybe at the time
when the Vedas were
written these were things
that people would go meditate
and do in the forest.
You have the Upanishads, which means
to sit close to, or sit near.
And if you look at the Upanishads,
it really is referring to
sitting close, or near a teacher,
there's a lot of dialog
between student and teacher.
And the Upanishads, in particular,
really form the spiritual
core of Hinduism,
it really focuses around
spiritual philosophy.
And amongst these four Vedas,
there are 108 Upanishads,
and 108 is considered a very
auspicious number in Hinduism.
Now you also have Brahmanas,
which are commentary.
Now to be clear, there
are verses in the Vedas
that can be many of these,
that can be Aranyakas and Upanishads,
so these things are
not mutually exclusive.
Now in the Hindu tradition,
one of the unifying factors
are the Vedas and the sub-classifications,
or sub-categorizations of the Vedas,
these are often viewed
as divine revelations.
Even though the Vedas themselves,
some of the authors refer
to themselves as authors,
as people who are
introspecting on these ideas
and writing about them, it is believed
by many Hindus that this
is divine revelation.
And the term for that is Shruti.
And Shruti can also be
translated as what is heard,
you could argue what is heard
directly from the divine.
Now, in comparison to Shruti,
you also have this notion of Smriti.
Smriti can be translated
as what is remembered.
And there's a significant
number of Smriti texts,
some of them that are
also held very closely,
and meet the threshold of divine
scripture for many Hindus.
Now the most famous of the Smriti texts
are the famous Hindu epics.
So this is an image from the Ramayana.
The Ramayana tells a story of Rama,
who is one of Vishnu's incarnations,
going to save the
Princess Sita from Ravana.
The Mahabharata is a story
of really a family feud
between the Pandavas and the Kauravas.
You see here the Pandava
princes, the five Pandava princes
who are all married to Draupadi,
it's an interesting
story in the Mahabharata
how they did end up being
married to one princess.
And the most significant
part of the Mahabharata,
for modern day Hindus,
is the Bhagavad Gita.
It is a subset of the Mahabharata,
and the Mahabharata is quite long,
it will take you a while to read it,
but the Bhagavad Gita is quite short.
And the Bhagavad Gita takes place really
in the climax of the Mahabharata,
when you have the Battle of Kurukshetra,
where the Pandavas are fighting
their cousins the Kauravas.
And one of the Pandava brothers, Arjuna,
who's really considered
the greatest warrior
of the brothers, as he takes his chariot
into battle, his charioteer ends up
being Krishna, also an avatar of Vishnu.
And the Bhagavad Gita is
really about the conversation
between Krishna and Arjuna,
and it's all about Krishna
reassuring Arjuna not only
his role in the universe,
but it also becomes a
little bit of a layer
of the spiritual philosophy
discussed in the Upanishads.
In modern day India, the
Bhagavad Gita is probably
the scripture that is most
cited by modern Hindus.
So if you really want to
understand the spiritual core
of Hinduism, the best place
to look are the Upanishads,
and you also have the Bhagavad Gita,
which even though it's
part of the Mahabharata,
which is considered Smriti, it is revered,
and is often considered to be
divinely revealed, by Hindus.
Now this isn't a comprehensive listing
of all of the scripture
that is important to Hindus.
Obviously you have the Vedas,
which are very ancient.
Even these epics, their
events might have taken place
3,000 years ago, or maybe more;
their composition was
over 2,000 years ago,
they were canonized
during the Gupta Empire,
but there's many other texts.
You have things that are believed written
during the Vedic Period, the Vedanta,
which relate to things like
medicine and astronomy.
You have commentaries on
things like the Upanishads,
things like the Brahama Sutra.
You have the Puranas, which
literally means the old things,
and these are a whole collection
of old stories, epics, etc.
So Hinduism, as I mentioned, it is a
very broad religion, it
is a very diverse religion
and you even see that in the texts.
I'll now leave you with
a final excerpt from
the Bhagavad Gita, and what's
interesting about this,
as I mentioned, is the
parallels that it gives
to what we see in the
Upanishads, and some of what
we looked at on the first
video on Brahman and Atman.
The man who sees me in everything
and everything within me will not be
lost to me, nor will
I ever be lost to him.
So this is Krishna talking to Arjana,
and Krishna's saying me, you could
say God, or the Ultimate Reality.
He who is rooted in
oneness realizes that I am
in every being; wherever
he goes, he remains in me.
When he sees all being as
equal in suffering or in joy
because they are like himself,
that man has grown perfect in yoga.
And the term yoga, in
modern day, often refers to
the type of stretching, and
exercising, and body postures
that you might even
have at your local gym,
but it's really a more general term
of how do you connect to
that Ultimate Reality?
And some of what you might
learn in a yoga class
is one mechanism, leveraging the body,
but there's other techniques,
through meditation
and other things, other forms of yoga
that are trying to get the individual
to better recognize the illusion,
the Maya around them, and get connected
to the oneness of the Ultimate Reality.